music
Hello, hi, hello, hello, welcome, huh, ah, sorry, okay, I'm going to be a little, little
energy today, um, I don't know, it's just been a tiring day, I don't know why, um, but
thank you for coming to the stream, um, I have a thing to talk about, um, um, um, let me find it, hold on,
um, what is my thing, what did I want to talk about, this is what I wanted to talk about,
um, I have a new ASMR up, so if you didn't watch it, there's a link in chat, you should
watch it, um, here, I'll, should I pin it, no I'm too lazy to pin it, well there's a
fucking link, uh, watch it, I worked semi-hard on it, oh my headphones keep hitting the mic,
I worked semi-hard on it, I, um, I wanted to get a video out soon because my last ASMR was
eight days ago and that felt like it was getting a little long, so I, um, I just improved it, normally
I would want, I would write a script, but sometimes when I don't have time, um, I just improv it, um,
because, you know, it's easier, and also I wanted to say thank you so much for 100K views
on my ASMR, my cat girl ASMR collab with Kaifu, I haven't, I haven't told her that we got 100 views
yet, I don't know if she's been keeping up with the video, but that's so cool, it's so cool that we
got 100,000 views, that's, it was literally like the, it was the second video I made, and it was
the first video I guess I made without the help of like, um, anyone in Vila, because Strani, um,
scripted the first one, she scripted everyone's first video, so yeah, 100K is so cool, 1 million,
oh no, no, no, no, no, no, it won't get to 1 million probably, but it's cool that we got 100K,
I hope I get more videos that reach 100K views, I used to get them all the time, but that's because,
Yandere is like a really popular genre, and it's a popular niche, and I understand why it's a
popular niche, because I love it too, but now I'm doing like normal, normie stuff, so I don't know
if I can, I don't know if I can pretend to be normie enough to attract the other normies, you know?
We'll see, we'll see, um, make an ASMR where you beat us over the head with your rats, no, no I won't,
no, that's weird and not, it's not even Mimi, P.L.V. you're getting beat over the head with rats,
what do you mean? Cisclon is normie? Oh, is that you facing me? Sorry, I have my mic in a different
position today because I'm doing a hand cam, Cisclon isn't kind of normie, isn't like,
isn't, isn't, um, in sense like one of the most popular tags on corn, hub, c-c-c-c-corn, I'm talking
about corn right now, on the hub of corn, Yandere is overrated, don't say that in front of me,
don't say that in front of me, I like the genre, I like it, it's not overrated to me,
yeah it's very popular on the cob, it's not really, you know, I guess it is normie, I don't know,
anyways, um, let me switch over to hand cam, I forgot to change, okay,
that was on my speaker, sorry, thank you, I'm glad you liked it, oh something I wanted to do,
I completely forgot, fuck it, I'll do it right now, so I'm going to, I'm going to change,
how do I do this, I'm going to change the minimum for the text to speech,
um, yeah, I'm going to change the minimum, so for the tip for both of them, the new minimum
amount will be, is $5 okay, I think I'll change it to $5, hold on, minimum amount, no not minimum
to show, minimum for text to speech, like it'll still show up, um, and I can maybe still read it,
but um, I won't do text to speech, so minimum amount to trigger text to speech, I'll do $5,
because I understand that sometimes it can get a little spammy, and then um,
that's for the tip, and then I'm going to do the same for super chat too,
okay, sorry, my keyboard is far away from me, so I have to move, all right, there we go, I,
I hope that worked, if not I'll try to fix it again, thank you for the $1 anonymous,
is having it only read out the text of the text to speech and not the name or don't know amount,
would speed up each message, well it's just that like, I don't know, I feel like one dollar is
just too um, little, sorry, I'm like adjusting my mic, are you gay, why are you acting so gay,
thank you anonymous for the $5, it worked, okay, I'm there, now I changed my sound
out, so it's not coming out of my um, my speakers, and now I can go over to the hand cam,
most vtubers have a minimum for text to speech, yeah, yeah, um, that's my minimum now,
yeah it's, it's super easy to spam text to speech with just one dollar, um,
oh,
I'm working on it, I'm working on it, oh wait, hold on, I didn't even turn on
the audio for the, there we go, why are you acting so gay, thank you for the $5,
I don't know, wait is that, is that an old one, wait, no, oh two people did the testing, oh,
what the fuck, or at least two anonymous,
anonymouses did the testing, I don't know, okay, well now the audio is on, so any
testing should be good, and you should hear it too, I heard the other one, I don't know,
I'm confused, um, this should be the screen, okay, uh, over here, hi, okay, there we go,
testing on lower range, okay $4.99, thank you anonymous, it didn't say it, but it did say the
are you gay, should I remove that too, is that annoying, do you hate the are you gay,
here's my hands, they look a little dirty for some reason, I promise they're clean, I don't know,
gay, why are you acting so gay, anonymous tipped $5, lucky me, I found $5 in front of a
blind crippled homeless dude's pants in front of the grocery store, oh thank you so much,
oh, oh my, are you gay, why are you acting so gay, my cue well tipped $5, hi amy, just testing as well,
also did streams start early, I arrived at $5.58 and the stream was already well on its way,
uh-huh, we started early, we did, thank you for the $5, and thank you for stealing $5 from the
blind crippled homeless man's pants too, the blind and crippled don't deserve money, you should take
it from them, your nails, two of your nails look shorter than the rest, ah, they literally broke,
it wasn't me, they broke, they, I swear it wasn't me, they broke, I don't know why,
I don't know what happened, but they broke, it wasn't me, also look how gross they are, oh,
my aunt did them and she really wanted to cut my cuticles, but I was like, no, I don't want you
to cut my cuticles, like, that hurts, you know, and so she was like, okay sure, I won't cut your
cuticles instead, I'll just push them back, and I was like, oh, yeah, sure, just push it, also sorry
if the camera's shaky, it's because my, my um, my desk is shaky, that's why, but I was like, sure,
yeah, just push them back, that's fine, and then she grabs like a really sharp tool, and she just
fucking goes ham on them, and at some point she gets like, I guess frustrated with pushing them,
this is getting annoying, I might have to take my headphones off, she gets like frustrated with
pushing them back, and she literally just starts cutting them with like the blunt tool that she
was using to push them back, and it hurts so fucking much, uh, like at the end I was like,
fuck, I should have just asked her to cut it off, it probably would have hurt the same amount,
she was like fucking, like rubbing a blunt tool against my cuticles, it fucking hurt,
I work as a cashier, and y'all kept mentioning five dollars, and the customer had to pay five
thirty, and I asked if they were gay, you've been watching too many Emmy streams,
how dare anyone of her Emmy, it's, it's my aunt, she gets aunt privileges of hurting me,
also I have a cup of water, I'm drinking water right now, and it's got a peach, or no wait,
sorry, it's got a tulip on the um, on the cat, yeah, fancy,
and it's water instead of a monster, okay, so um right, we need the rats, oh we need the rats,
okay well maybe first we can decide on which, which plant to make, so that way I can set it up
before the rats come and mess everything up, which plant do you want, should I like put a pool,
okay maybe we'll make like only one set today, so um maybe I can do it like this,
okay so here's our three sets, um this is one, this is two, this is three, okay I'm gonna make a
pool, and you can choose which one we do, you just choose one, two, or three, okay, oops that's the
wrong button, um pool, um start a pool, which, let go, set,
one, two,
or three, start pool, there you go,
or top middle bottom, that works too, but one, two, three, that's easy too, okay I'm,
I didn't think of it that way, but like this one's like I don't know red and, and, and purple and uh
green, and then this one's blue, and this one's got a cactus and shit, how much for you to
smash all the lego after building them, oh thank you for the, is that five dollars, I can't even see it,
um no amount of money, oh 7.99, thank you for the 7.99, um no amount of money, the point is that these
are, these are decorations, I don't want to smash them, I don't want to smash any of them,
they're cute, they're supposed to be decorative, I'm not gonna smash them, yeah you choose, oh my
god, okay it looks like number two is winning, so this one, you want this one, right, sorry the
glare on the, there's a lot of glare from the light, this one, okay I'll put that one,
if I can find it, there's this whole box, okay this is the box I got, you can't really, this is
the box I got, drop test the leg of flowers from three stories high, no thank you for the 30
dollars, but no, no how did that guy do it, where he like made his finger look really long,
how did he do it, you gotta like use the camera to your advantage, I saw like the meme where,
is it like this, no, how do you, how do you do it,
I'm trying to make it look long, I don't think I have the right camera perspective to make it
look long, whatever, no, that looks stupid, fuck you, do it,
no thank you for the 79.99 but no I'm not gonna do it, how do I know which one this belongs to,
this one has a four on it, do the numbers, are the numbers in here,
are you gay, why are you acting so gay,
oh thank you for the um one dollar, oh my god, Amy is fingering us,
I could be, also I know I said that um, I can't really tell which one this is,
there's no numbers in here, oh it says here, okay, it says on, okay, so I need backs five and six,
well there's three on the thing though,
what, wait what, where's the last one,
wait what, huh, why is this so long,
okay whatever, five and six,
six, that's two, this is three, this is one, where's five and six,
five, there it is, six, okay, Lego ASMR, isn't that such a nice sound,
I should do a Lego ASMR, POV building Legos with your little sister, okay,
okay, I'm gonna lower myself down here, okay, um and cancel that pull and pull, okay,
um, why does my stream look so much worse
on YouTube than it does in my um, I don't know, one day we'll have good camera quality,
one of these days we'll have good camera quality, mark my words, it'll happen,
it looks great, here what if I like make it bigger,
like that, and then turn these off, and then make it big,
I don't know why it's such a weird shape, there, now you can see how gross and stained my um,
my computer thing is, my computer mat, it looks fine, oh well you have low standards,
you should, you should raise your standards for vtubers, what are you doing watching me,
go watch someone else with good quality streams, like I don't know,
let's start with the big one, no let's start with the little ones, oh there's two in this one,
that's why, okay, like stronty or something or like sheebie, they have good quality streams,
right, I don't have a lot of time to watch their streams, sorry I know the camera's really shaky,
thank you for watching all my streams and audios, the clock,
what do you mean thank you, thank you for watching them, and thank you for the $30,
okay, I'm gonna close, I'm gonna close this um, box so that the rats can't
kidnap the other parts of the other plants, they'll still try to but,
and then I'm gonna close this Tupperware so they can't kidnap those parts,
they're safe in here, okay, and I'll go get them, BRB, well they're right behind me,
there's not much BRB but you know,
okay, I have the fan favorite here, Esteban, now Esteban recently I just noticed like yesterday,
unfortunately she has a tumor, she has a mammary tumor, I made an appointment with the vet,
it's two weeks from now, that was the fastest they could get me in,
so she will be getting surgery as soon as possible to get it removed, but um yeah,
so don't be afraid if you see a lump, I don't think it's visible, here she is, she hates me,
she hates me, she hates being held, I don't really think it's visible but if you do see it,
don't worry, I know it's there, come here, come here, okay she's off camera, but yeah,
yeah they're super prone to tumors, I've had lots of raps with tumors already so I know it happens
and uh, it doesn't surprise me anymore
there's um
cute fingies always, can't stick around, sorry I can't hear the text this week,
I just wanted to say love ya Amy and hope you have a good stream, oh my god hopefully you
didn't see my face in there
and then here's Pixie and then obviously um Dennis will not be, Dennis will not be touched by me,
um what did I miss, what did I miss, and also oh yeah uh thank you for this super chat, thank
you for the ten dollars, cute fingies always, can't stick around so gonna go, so gonna watch
later but wanted to say love you Amy, hope you have a good stream, thank you, thank you, okay
also thank you for becoming a pin pal demon seal, um hopefully the doctor helps, yeah
it should be fine, it's not, it doesn't look abnormal or anything, um
some tumors can be a little bit scary because they might be abnormal, this one looks pretty
normal though, so I, I'm not too worried, okay
didn't see anything Luna cute, they're quick, they don't like to be on camera all the time,
except for Esteban, apparently Esteban loves being on fucking camera, I had no clue,
um only face, I mean only rats, no face, okay good, good Dennis the menace, why did you write
menace as menus, Dennis the menus, okay, some of you guys may be a little bit too young to be
watching me if you don't know how to spell out menus, I mean menace, am I stupid, is this not
oh this is the pot, I kind of have an awkward angle here, um I don't have the best angle so
excuse me, she was born to be on camera, she's a little attention whore apparently, I was never
aware of that, she's a star, she was born to be a star, do you have your glasses on, yes I do,
I always have my glasses on, I always have to have my glasses on, I couldn't live my life
without my glasses, well I guess I could but I wouldn't be able to see anything, so yeah I do
have my glasses on, um I can't find, I can't find the next piece now, wait what the fuck
wait what the fuck
wait the next piece isn't in here, oh no it's in here I see it, I thought I was going crazy
immediately stuck on the third piece, bro you can't spell either, stock
immediately stuck on the first piece, no I don't deal with stocks,
we don't do stocks around here, not around here partner, not around here
this is going to be an endurance challenge, why, it's pretty chill so far
oh wait I'm supposed to put
we're chill, we're just chillin
rats already stole it, no they didn't, it's here, it's here
no I'm not stuck, shut up calm down, calm yourselves, calm yourselves
it's chill, maybe I'll even be able to get through more than one
I believe Lil sis can do this in a stream, easy peasy, you don't even have to believe
because it's going to happen, it's going to happen easily, anyways I don't know, we should
talk about something, what's the recent vtuber news, um, stocks vtubing agency girls I think
are debuting right now as we speak, which is cool, um, one of my friends I think auditioned
to stocks vtubing agency, I'm not sure, I'm not sure if she did or not to be honest, I can't
remember, I think she wanted to, um, I saw it, I saw their auditions and I was like
a meme or making a vtubing agency, what the fuck is going on here, thank you for the member,
I'm sure the typos are coming from phone posters, autocorrect must be the origin of the first I
am I, yeah probably, probably, I'm just shitting on them for it
do they show stocks, they do not show stocks, fork makes some of the craziest drawings, he does
but I was kind of like, like when I saw the auditions, because this was before I got into
the viewer, I was like, wait, why is he starting a vtubing agency, um, because he's a memeor,
right, I was like, what, did I put this in the wrong hole, I don't know, I was very confused,
I hope the girls do well though, and I hope the company does well too
don't let your dreams be memes, exactly, don't let your dreams just be memes,
if you want to start a vtubing agency, go ahead and do it, that's not true, don't do it,
don't, don't, don't do it, um, I remember Strani, she told me, she's like,
Amy, Amy, whatever you do, don't ever start a vtubing agency, she was like, don't,
don't start a vtuber agency, Amy, I'm guessing it's a lot of stress, yeah, don't,
yeah, stay a big brother, don't start a vtubing agency,
my dream is to marry little sis, don't let your dreams just be dreams, it'll happen,
don't you worry, it'll happen,
though I don't really want to get married like in front of people,
my dream marriage is just to like order Uber Eats and lots of wine, and like, I don't know,
party alone together, and like, preferably do all the paperwork through mail,
but I don't know if that is possible, ah, no, okay, I was scared a rat was gonna get it,
cause it fell down, a classy woman, yep, a courthouse marriage, not even courthouse,
don't even, I don't even want to go in the courthouse, a home marriage, can we just call
the courthouse via zoom and do it that way, can that, can that work, same weddings are
expensive and boring, I mean, it's not to like, I don't want to shit on girls that, that want to do
weddings, cause you know, it's like, I don't understand, I don't understand this one,
it's a lot of people's dreams to have really cool weddings and I don't want to shit on people's
dreams, I just wouldn't be able to plan one, I feel like that's too stressful for me,
and there's too many eyes and there's too many people on me, like, all the people staring at
you, I, I don't want my family to see me be like, lovey-dovey with someone else either,
that's like, kind of cringe to me and scary, like I don't want my family to know that I have like
feelings and stuff, you know, tell the court we have COVID, yeah, and gotta isolate at home,
but want to wed anyways, yeah, exactly, that's what we'll tell them, we got gold, we got scurvy,
we need some vitamin C, yeah, totally good, moderators, are you banned for Russian vocabulary,
what, moderators or have you been banning the Russians, I mean please use English in chats,
so if you're not using English in chat, that's a good reason,
it's hard to be vulnerable in front of others, yeah, exactly, I don't want to be vulnerable in
front of people, so that's why I wouldn't want a big, a big, big, big, crazy wedding and stuff,
you know, Russians in chat, I can smell them, there's a Russian nearby, oops that's not the
right thing, wedding sounds too much to dress up and prepare for, that too, that too, it's a lot,
it's a lot of stuff to do, I kind of want to watch like SpongeBob or something while doing this,
wait how, fuck, I think I did this wrong,
how shaky is the camera right now, I feel like it's constantly shaking a little bit,
I think it is,
oh whatever,
I simply yell, I object that every wedding you, oh simply yell, I object that every,
chat's going too fast, hold on, at every wedding you attend so that no one invites you anymore,
I've never been invited to a wedding before though, so it doesn't matter, yeah it has been not a lot,
um,
sorry I'm just tightening the camera, yeah that probably didn't do anything, whatever,
and this one goes this way, maybe,
me's hands are giving us the shakes, if I ever get married can I invite you,
what do you mean, if you ever get married I'd already be there because I'd be the bride,
can I invite you,
what am I doing wrong,
I don't understand what am I doing wrong,
oh there we go,
you mean a wedding dress, never, you'll never see it, it'll never happen,
there we go,
still debating on whether or not to invite the bride to my wedding,
that reminds me of Icy's um, that reminds me of Icy's uh, clip of her marrying all her,
all her snowberries, if you haven't seen um, some of the, the vtuber clip or made a clip of Icy and
they'd like, made an edit, a photoshop edit of her like marrying all her snowberries,
and there was a bunch of guys in a line,
there was a bunch of guys in a line, um,
waiting to marry, Icy is this wrong, yes it is wrong,
I think all the rats just went back into their cage, they were done with me, is that it,
holy shit we already made one, look at me go bro, look at it,
it's so cute, ah it's so cute, look at it, sorry I'm covering the, I'm covering my iPhone right
now so the tracking is gone, look how cute it is, I did it, nice, okay there we go,
now my face is back, all right there's one, past the tutorial level, oh shit now we have to make,
wait, we went from this tiny one to, to, to the big cactus, oh frick okay,
it's bigger than me, oh it's not, okay well yeah it is, but that's because I brought it really
close, look at me, hold on can I squish me,
how do I, how do I squish myself, squish, squish, squish, squish, hold on, hold on,
there I am, and I can squish myself, well I can't actually but I can hold myself,
I'm holding myself, in my little hand,
I offer you one emmy, okay,
back to Liko building, what other VTuber news has there been lately, um
you accept my offer, thank you,
I watched, um,
how's the beehole doing after the chill, it hurt a little bit at first but I'm okay now,
I'm okay, your hands are so pretty, bro they're so average, fucking um,
you know how it's pretty hands, Strawny has pretty hands, Strawny has really pretty hands,
I would lick her hands if she let me,
VTuber news drama, yeah like, like I, I like drama, I like drama channels,
and I watch them, I finished watching um, the story of um,
fuck, it was the Nijisanji thing where like, two of their VTubers were kind of um,
in a dispute I guess, because um,
because one of them was like copying the other girl's like voice and way of speaking, I forgot,
do you know what I'm talking about though,
Roa, yeah, Mero and Roa, Roa, fucking hell, Roa, I just finished watching that story,
wait, is this the right one, oh it's on the outside,
and how, was it Roa who stopped streaming, that's old like 2021, I know but like,
I had to catch up okay, I had to, I had to catch up on the news, yeah,
yeah she's been on hiatus for years, probably because of that I'm guessing,
I kind of live under a rock unless it's related to you, that's okay, that's how it should be,
but if you guys got any like, almost like the shy lily situation, oh dude,
the shy lily situation, I feel so bad for shy lily, man, if you don't know that situation,
I'll explain it because apparently, apparently you, you live under a rock and you're not obsessed
with drama like I am, obsessed with other people's drama, okay, not obsessed with my own drama,
we stay out of drama here, but we like to listen to other people's drama, it's because my life
is so boring, I need, I need other people's drama to like fill in, fill in the blank spots, you know,
but if you don't know, a vtuber was like accused of
copying shy lily's design and copying shy lily's voice
and kind of everyone on twitter and probably other social medias too went on like a witch hunt of her,
what are your guys thoughts about that and then they even pressured shy lily into responding to
yeah, small lola, her name was small lola, give me your thoughts, give me your thoughts and opinions
and I'll read them, fuck, let me open this, it's a little ironic that she used to face the same
allegations herself before, oh yeah, didn't, wasn't shy lily accused of copying um, I don't remember
her name, vey, vey, vey, vey's um, voice, right, most of the vtubers are, most of the vtubers are
pretty cringe and it's not my jam, oh fuck, I have to scroll up, but I like vealer because you girls
are cool, cool and pretty funny and you guys most importantly of all are genuine and I respect that
I feel like we're not that much different from other vtubers but I'm glad you like us
but you should check out other vtubers too, most of them are pretty normal, at least if you like
go the, oh my god my voice is cracking so much, if you go the indie route and find like smaller
ones, they're mostly normal, mostly, no thoughts, don't care about it, fair
there was a time when shirley, oh yeah, yeah when she was compared to vey, but yeah, it's not nice
to pressure the main person to make some sort of statement when they don't want to, but to not
bother, yeah that's true, I feel really bad because like no matter what she says, what she says,
people are gonna come after her for it, you know, thank you for becoming a pinpell silver
it's fine to use her as inspiration but lola should have known people would point out the
similarity so she should have put more effort into differentiating herself to avoid trauma
true
true, the veal or drama are gonna go crazy, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't think so,
I don't know, what do you guys think we would get into drama for, something crazy, I remember people
on twitter before we even debuted, they were like, I can't wait until all these whores get accused of
grooming, I don't know, I feel like we wouldn't get into drama for that, that's like, nah
I'm missing more stuff
this one, this one, this one, one, two, three, four, one, two, one, two, one, two,
murder, the critical video on image drama, that'd be hilarious, I'd be the first to watch that one
getting banned on youtube for live orgasms
what, what, that's crazy, none of us would ever do that, that's crazy
I feel like one weird toy that has to get viral and the normies will point out that loli and
win says, possible, possible, possible, maybe not because of you guys doing something bad,
but some other models throwing shade at you, like seeking out trouble
is it even grooming if we know and accept getting groomed?
but no, I think, I don't know, maybe they met like the other kind of grooming, like the grooming of
minors, what am I doing, what am I doing, I don't understand
do you just eat illegal?
no, that one wasn't obvious, oh my god, I actually put it in my mouth, I didn't mean to do that
it was gonna be the trace of you, my thoughts on, my bets are on, no I'm kidding, I'm not
betting on anyone, no one, no one, I'm just joking, no, no, we wouldn't get into drama
the children yearn for the minds, we wouldn't get into drama, we're nice and wholesome
what, I'll like this, okay and then do that twice
sis chokes on Legos and fucking dies, that's our drama, we choke on Legos and die
the bad girls spit out the Legos, there you go, I spat it out
I mean when you get popular you'll eventually get drama if only because of the corn is bad
people, but it is what it is, that's possible, that is possible, yeah
if you keep trying to eat the Legos, Big Bro will have to take them away from you,
just try and stop me, I will store them, oh wait, no yeah, I will store them in my mouth and you'll
never find them, I think I did this wrong, this doesn't look right, that doesn't look the same
what
Ahem.
Stir them up, my ass.
What's the context here?
Ah, we're talking about drama.
What would Vilaer get into drama for?
Okay, this was right from the start.
Gay? Why are you acting so gay?
That would be a cute one to make.
Okay, I figured out what I did wrong.
Thank you for the five dollars.
You'll have to put a finger up and search on my butt for the lego-
Oh my god. I'm gonna shit on your hand.
I'm gonna poop all over your hand.
Yup, that's what I'll do.
Don't test me. I'll do it.
I'll shit all over your hand and you'll never touch my butt again.
There we go. Now I got it right.
We have been suffering from an intense lack of rats.
Ah fuck, I have to do it twice more?
Even suffering from an intense lack of rats in this stream, I'm sorry.
They come out when they want to and I guess right now they don't want to come out.
No shitting on my fingers.
Vilaer drama would be something like they get drunk and forgot to close OBS and pull a dark side fill.
But you can see what they go into.
Wait, what happened to dark side fill?
Can't wait until Amy starts fistfighting her chin, right?
I would never.
But if I did, I would win for sure.
Wacked it on stream, jorked it live?
Oh shit.
I wouldn't know.
I'm not that horny that I just pulled down my pants and jork it right after streaming.
Okay, that's not true.
Most of the time, most of the time, I don't, I don't.
That's crazy.
Wrestling match? Oh my god, we should do a 3D wrestling match.
That would be funny.
That would be so funny.
We need to get together in real life for that though.
Dang it.
She's zirking it live on stream.
Vilaer drama would be when someone does a Twitter space and thinks they ended the space and then they say they hate their fans.
Oh my god.
That would be, that would be the drama.
He jorked it on stream seven years ago.
Poor dude will never live that down.
Well hey, maybe it got him some fans, you know?
Maybe it got him some fans.
It got him some attention, you know?
I don't, I don't know.
He got something, something out of it, right?
Vilaer mud wrestling off collab?
No, it would, it would be a, it wouldn't be mud wrestling.
Why, naked mud wrestling?
No, no, no.
It would be real wrestling.
In a wrestling rink and everything.
And Strani would be like the microphone person, you know?
The newscaster?
No, that's not right.
Wait, this isn't right.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Yeah, like WWE wrestling.
Commentator, yeah, the commentator.
That's where she would be.
Lube wrestling? No.
I could be, I could wear the rat suit.
I guess, maybe.
But it would, wait.
Oops, I put this one wrong.
Come on.
Here we go.
It would be in like 3D.
So I would have to get a...
I would have to get an outfit
of a rat suit in 3D.
Oh, I put this on the other way.
Okay, that's why.
Man, these things are so confusing.
Man, these things are so confusing for
stupid me.
Nacho Libre.
What's Nacho Libre?
Is that a wrestler?
Remy?
Why would you...
Oh, Remy, for like,
for like a...
What's the guy's name around?
Remy?
Oh my god.
Remy the wrestler.
And my signature move
can be the rim job.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, there we go.
I finished the pot.
Let's go.
Yay.
Remy Bezu.
I don't even know what's a rim job.
Oh, you don't...
You don't know?
You don't know what a rim job is?
Should I explain to you what a rim job is?
Would you like to know?
Would you like to learn?
He doesn't know?
You want me to enlighten you?
Oh, fuck. Alright.
Well, don't say I didn't warn you.
Okay, I didn't warn you.
A rim job, you see,
is when you have the,
you know, the donut hole here.
Oh, you finished the donut hole.
You got the donut hole.
You got the donut hole,
and you just, um,
play with it
with your, but with your mouth.
Yeah.
I'm being gross, sorry.
Yeah, when you, when you,
your tongue punch it,
and you can make it bigger.
Okay, whatever, whatever.
Next, next, next.
Next, next step.
We're almost done. That's surprising.
I'm getting mega hot in this room, though,
because I'm wearing your sweater.
Pacific Rim.
Is that a video game? I think that's a video game, right?
But, but there's poop in there.
Kachan, but there's poop in,
I just spat all over my face.
But, but Kachan,
there's poop in there.
It's fine.
Just do it, Deku.
Oh, no, that's not right.
Oh, there he is.
What is it asking me to do?
But I poop in there.
You,
you don't want my poop, do you?
Oh, what?
I'm getting so confused.
How do I do this? Oh, fuck.
Do you think Deku's gonna like
his new job at McDonald's? Wait, what do you mean?
What is that referencing?
Are you getting
tired of my poop jokes?
Do you hate me in my poop jokes?
I think they're funny.
You think the green lego tastes,
you think the green lego
tastes like green apple?
I don't know.
Let's see if it does.
Lego tastes testing.
No, not really.
It kind of tastes more like
microplastics.
Is that right?
They managed to get there so straight.
Why is mine so not straight?
My hand is starting to hurt
from this.
I'll taste the same.
Conspiracy theory.
It's like when they try to trick us into thinking
fruit loops all tasted the same.
I mean, no. It's like when they try to
trick us into thinking fruit loops all tasted
differently, but in reality they all tasted
the same.
These
capitalist corporate scammers
thinking we're
stupid,
thinking we're not going to notice that all
the legos taste the same.
I did this wrong, didn't I?
That's a mega plastic?
Well, I'll turn it into
a microplastic once it enters my mouth.
And I crush it up.
Everyone knows that just like crayons,
the red one tastes the best.
I don't know.
Wait, what the fuck? Oh, I'm messing it up.
What does your mouth taste like?
It tastes like I haven't brushed my teeth in the past
12 hours. That's what it tastes like.
You want to taste it?
Here we go.
Does Amy bite her nails? No.
They just broke off because they're long.
They broke off.
And they broke off very conveniently.
Very conveniently.
Mm-hmm, plaque.
Activated elements.
What's an activated element?
I have not licked the switch cartridges.
No.
But I kind of want to try.
Would you encourage me to lick the switch cartridges
if you were here with me?
I feel like I don't want to...
I don't want to break any of my video games,
so I'm kind of worried
about licking the switch cartridges,
but maybe
I would be open to licking a DS cartridge
because I have a lot of DS games that I don't care about.
Would you want to play a DS game with me ever?
There was one point in time...
Fuck.
There was one point in time
where I was really, really committed
into doing, um...
Um...
What's it called?
A speedrun
of this one really niche
DS game.
So that way I could be on the speedrun
record website
because, like, the one person who,
you know, speedran this DS game
because no one else fucking plays
this random ass DS game.
But I never fucking ended up doing it.
I think I'd want to do it with you, maybe.
I think it'd be really fun
to, like, speedrun a game with me,
except it wouldn't even be a speedrun.
It would just be a regular playthrough
because, um, no one else has speedrun the game,
so I can basically go at whatever pace I want
because no matter how slow I go,
it'll still be the record for that website.
Is it called speedrun.com
or something like that? I think it is.
What if there's someone already on the leaderboard?
No, it's a really niche game.
There was, like,
one person on the leaderboard
for one of the game modes,
but for the regular game mode,
there was no one on the leaderboard.
The only problem is if I,
like, stream myself speedrunning it,
um, someone else is going to be like,
oh, I'm going to beat her.
I have the game, I'm going to beat her, you know?
DSR Childhood.
It's my childhood.
For most people, it's not their childhood.
Their childhood is, like, I don't know,
the fucking SNES
or the GameCube or something.
A lot of people use that technique.
Just take advantage of the fact that nobody else
has bothered to speedrun
Tomba 2 or some shiz, yeah.
And it's 64. That one too, yeah.
That one too.
And Game Boy, yeah, that one too.
I grew up with Pictochat too.
Oh shit, my phone's gonna die.
Mm-hmm, PlayStation 2.
Yes, PlayStation.
All of those.
All of those games
are a lot of people's childhoods.
Mine was mostly the DS.
I was poor and had an SNES
when all my friends had an N64.
Oh please, what's the difference?
I don't know.
But at least you have something, you know?
You have a...
You still have a console.
Oh no, I gotta twist it like this.
Um...
Wait, how do I twist it?
Oh.
Like that.
And then like this.
Um...
Oh.
Oh, this is hard to do.
Why does mine not look as twisty as theirs?
What am I doing wrong?
Huh?
Oh, there we go.
Mine doesn't look as twisty as theirs.
3D models to pixels in me?
What does that mean?
What does that mean? What do you mean by that?
Are you comparing the different game consoles?
Ah!
I just spilled a bunch of
freaking Lego pieces, fuck.
No, I spilled one and it's gone!
Fuck!
Oh shit, I don't see it anywhere.
No!
Oh wait, I found it.
I hope that was the only one.
I don't know if any more fell.
Ugh.
The rats have made their presence known.
Nah.
I don't think they want to come out.
N64 has
early 3D polygons.
The SNES was 64 bit.
Oh!
Yeah, see, I didn't know that.
My cousins had a genesis
in older consoles like SNES.
Mmm.
What's a genesis?
What is a genesis?
Oop.
Sega.
Sega!
Okay, I see.
Imi.
What do you mean, Imi?
Genesis is Mega Drive? What's a fucking Mega Drive?
Mega Drive.
Oh, I'm done.
I'm done this one.
I'm turning into dust.
Showing your normies' roots?
What?
Is it because I don't know all these, all these, um,
these games?
Game systems?
Here's the next one.
There we go, there's the other one.
It looks pretty close to the original.
Right? That looks about right.
I feel so old now.
You're such a zoomer? I am a zoomer.
Sorry, I'm covering the camera.
I am a zoomer, yeah.
There it is.
Two down.
My childhood games were like,
Mario Kart.
Keep in mind though, I didn't get, um,
I didn't get a DS until I was like,
Ah shit, how old was I?
I don't remember.
I want to say I didn't get a DS
until like,
like seventh grade,
maybe? Sixth grade?
Maybe like six,
six or seventh grade?
So, um,
yeah,
maybe seventh grade.
How old are you in seventh grade?
I don't know.
Twelve?
Are you twelve in seventh grade?
Twelve, yeah.
Yeah.
I didn't have much experience with consoles or anything.
Um, okay.
Okay, now I need the last.
I need this one.
They give you extra pieces.
That's nice.
Okay, so it's okay that I dropped some.
Oh, by then I was playing with 3DS.
Yeah, the 3DS had come out, but
I only got the regular one.
Snack time.
I want some snacks.
Some, some variety pack.
Yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum.
This one seems really big.
I don't know if I can do this one.
This one seems like a lot.
Should I?
This one's a lot.
Maybe I should take a quick break and then I'll continue.
Okay, I'm going to take a quick break.
Um, this one's like the biggest one, right?
I'm going to take a quick break and then I'll continue.
This is where it starts.
Alright, I'll be back in like, uh,
five minutes.
Maybe maximum ten.
But I think five.
Okay?
Okay, baby.
Let's go.
I'm back.
little bit cooler and
I fanned myself with two fans this one included
Oh, now you can see the fan and you can see that I'm not using anything that's vibrating and it's literally just a fan
It doesn't make the fan sound I
Should like fan my chest here
That's nice get underneath there. Oh my god imagine if I showed oh my god if I lean forward too much
Should I do it?
I'm not wearing a shirt. I'm just wearing a sweater. I'm not wearing a shirt. That'd be crazy
Hey, Amy, I'm going to an oddity festival tomorrow and they have a rat taxidermy class. Should I take it?
Should I lean forward a little? Should I? I want to now. It is bueno, yeah
Someone got me like a really big pack of bueno because I tweeted out that I want chocolate when I wake up from my nap and I did it
No, I won't do it
See you say you say bless us, but like
No, is that even allowed on YouTube I
Know that's straw you like
Doesn't strong you like censor boobs in her thumbnails and stuff and in her videos because it's not allowed
You know, let me zip up my sweater and see see how
See how far I need to lean in how far do I need to lean in oh I need to lean in a lot
Okay, that's not my tits. That's just the sweater
Don't worry. It's not my boobs. It's the sweater
Ah fuck I need to look there you get you can get that
That's what you can get
Yeah, everyone's calling me flat because they want me to say no and try to prove them wrong, right?
You want me to be like, ooh, I'm not flat and then whip out my tits
Just to prove you wrong. Well, it's not gonna happen. It's not gonna happen
How long is that pee I don't know I need pee I don't know
Nobody will complain if you did yes, they would
Also, sorry
You should take the rat taxidermy class. Yes. Thank you for the five dollars and
Also, thank you for the five dollars while I was gone. I am the best sister in the world
Are you saving it for an OS stream? No
Just fell to my knees in a Walmart
Because I showed you a piece of my sweater
Here if someone donates how much should I put it at
If someone donates four hundred dollars, I'll do a I'll do a
Chest but reveal a
Little bit of a chest but reveal there a little bit of a chest but reveal
Anyways, otherwise we can continue
They're gonna do it no, they're not gonna do it
And I'm gonna do it. It's okay
And you're gonna try windows before they could they're so good they're really freaking good. They're my favorite chocolate brand
Other than like the
Dalarama knockoff
Which are like 25 cents each are they 50 cents each?
Can you repeat the number I forgot four hundred?
Four hundred is the number
I can't find oh, it's in here a
Texture of Buenos is so good it is
What if we make it collectively no no well you accidentally show take a TKB. What's TKB?
What's TKB my freaking desk keeps opening
TK breezy, what's TK breezy?
Chikubi nipples no no, I'll show you a crack. I'll show you a chest crack and that's it
No
Windows minis are my favorite treat to eat mmm Windows minis are good, too
I just prefer the big ones because like I
Don't know I end up eating like all of the windows minis. I don't know when to stop
Tata USD USD yep, I'm making a USD
The only chocolate I was really into our Charleston shoes. I've never heard of that
Those aren't the minis no it was a full-size well I threw the packaging away, but it was a full-size
Kinder fiesta is really good. Yeah, I've never tried Kinder fiesta. What is that?
Don't do it if you're not financially stable don't be stupid come on you're smarter than that don't be stupid
Don't be silly
You are stupid yeah
The sweater being this happens because the sweater shrinks in the wash while the zipper stays the same
Thank you for that fun fact, but I
But I swear that um I
Swear I've gotten the penis like even before washing a sweater
You know thank you for the
Thank you for the super chat the two-dollar super chat. Oh, no 400 on Yu-Gi-Oh cards
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
$400 worth every penny
And I'm even nervous
Thank you for the five dollars
Man, okay. Oh my god
I'm shy now, okay
I only unzipped it a little bit. How should I like push them together?
This is scary. Ah, okay. Just a little bit. Just a little bit. Okay, just just just
Just
Unzip all the way. There's no point in unzipping all the way
I'm wearing like a really old sports bra
Like a really old sports bra
Just just a little oh
You can seal oh fuck I gotta show flesh don't I how do I lean enough?
There you can get that
Ethernity tip to fifty dollars. I have something witty for this too
It's barely a crack
Should I can't even push them together. I can't it's the valley in between there you go
I
Mean what nothing happened
Guys, did you see that? Holy shit someone someone someone cut that out of the video. I can't leave that in I
Can't leave that in I got to cut that out someone clip that and download it before I delete it
Nothing happened
That's good, that's good what you're on top of things I
Can't find I
Can't find oh it's in here clipped in shift
I
Didn't know you guys were so desperate for just a little bit of a little tiny reveal
Did you miss something no you didn't miss anything nothing happens. We're still just building like those here
That's all you miss a single thing
What the fuck is this isn't all this stuff getting covered
Why do I need to put a wheel
The clip is spreading like wildfire in the fan discord it's okay. I
Hope that's allowed on YouTube. I didn't really do much. I
Didn't really do much
Watch my channel get fucking deleted because of that that would suck
No, I won't
Why are you calling what why are you calling them warlocks?
What is what
For what reason are you calling them warlocks? I
Can't find the last piece well not the last piece, but the next piece. I
Really don't like the sound of them clinking together
Is this it
There's a youtuber who plays piano in a bikini regular and she's still up that's true. I saw her she's really talented
Good for her. Is it in here? Oh
It's there, okay
Am I the first girl to show a little bit of
Tiddage on stream, I think so unless she be did maybe she be did during her. I don't remember I wasn't there
Unfortunately, I wish I could watch more of the other girls, but
The only one I usually I'm able to catch as I see because she does it at a convenient time for me
I'm like shaking now because I was so nervous
Thank you for the $400
Oh
I'm supposed to push it. No, I think that's it
Maybe stream but not in general. Yeah, no not in general but on stream though
Whoa
Bye is next time I
Know about that
You can have feet
There's my foot all the paint chaff chipped off now. Here's the other one
They're a little dirty I think from the floor
Hey, oh my god, I saw people made edits of um I
Saw people made edits of when I uh did that that gesture with my feet
You want it again? Oh
My god, I can't stay say so for like even two seconds
Okay, my pillow's falling off my my chair
Yeah, I'm so brave today
What is this
I
Anyways, I've been playing that um
To the spa. I know I need to go to like a spa one day. I've never been to a spa
I've never um
Need to I've never gotten like a massage or anything. I feel like I need to treat myself one day
I've never even gotten my nails done other than like by my aunt
So I really want to one day
You'll give me a massage and I
Feel like I want like a fancy one, you know, I don't want I don't want some amateur massage. I
Want a fancy massage?
I'm like a fancy person that knows how to massage. I have fancy establishment
That costs way too much money, but they oil up your body and make you all shiny
And they give you a happy ending. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. No, no, no, no, no
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I don't do those places even exist in Canada. I don't know I
Would not know
Are you saying we're not fancy? Well, I want like a fancy establishment, you know
Like actually maybe I don't maybe I'm too shy for that. I don't know
Cuz don't you have to get naked or something like you have to take off your clothes and then they just like
This is a chicken foot. What is this?
That chicken foot
Had a worry about freezing your bits off freezing. Is it cold?
Yeah, if you can pronounce the name it's not fancy enough
It's got to be at like some crazy super expensive hotel or something
She'd do a ham on and get a Turkish Turkish massage. They give you the good treatment with the sponge and stuff
What's the difference between a regular massage and a Turkish massage? I
Know that there's different types of massages and you don't have to get naked for all of them
But you at least have to take off your shirt for like a back massage, right? And I'm even scared to do that
Because like
No, I'm too scared to do that
I can't pronounce the little Caesars. Let's go there. Well, I can so let's not go there
Let me see that this one
They speak Turkish when they do with the massage. Oh, oh, that's okay. I can't pronounce or anything in Turkish. Okay. Yeah
They'll strip your skin raw. I kind of want that too
Amy boob camp easy was scared to get a professional massage. Yes. Yes
And I haven't done no boob cam. I don't know what you're talking about talking about I've never done that
Maybe that can be like a
Imagine that would be like a a donathan reward
I just have a boob cam
Oh my god, that would have to be like $60,000 that would have to be really high reward
Oh
Last one is gray. I hope that's okay. I can't find another white one
Oh, there's the other white one
Oh
As long as you go to actual professionals, it should be fine. Yeah, there's your drama
Have you considered a chiropractor not scared of chiropractors because I've heard stories of chiropractors like fucking up people's lives
like like like literally causing people to like have um
You know like uh
Like I don't know like breaking their necks and stuff. Haven't you heard those stories?
Hey sneeze
No
You would definitely not be the first person to
The masseuse ever saw naked and probably not the first person they saw naked that day. I know
But it's still shy like I'm still shy about it
I'm still shy about it
It's real life where real people can see me
It's not the internet where I'm just sitting in front of my computer and leaning over a little bit, you know
I
Yeah, chiro's a scam. Yeah, that's what I heard people say like
You know, it's it's dangerous in a scam. There's a shit ton of chiropractors near me though
And I always think that there's some sort of like a front for like, um
What's it called?
Um
Oh
I always think there's some sort of front for money laundering
You know, oh, I didn't do this, right? Oh shit
Oh shit, yeah money laundering
I messed it up
Chiropractors are a bit mixed some can realign a spine others have no idea what they're doing
Yeah, because isn't there like not any kind of official school for chiropracting?
Is this right?
That doesn't look right
Whatever
Like I heard there's nothing official for chiropractors. They just fucking do whatever they want
All right, what am I wrong?
There are plenty of massage places that are just fronts for
Boston tuition. I heard of that. Yeah, I know about that
Uh
In america slash canada, there's no official school in the uk. There's required medical school degree
Why don't they do that in america and canada?
The government must be making money off of us going to chiropractors and getting hurt
That's the conspiracy didn't strongly do a conspiracy theory stream. I should do a conspiracy three theory stream
I've watched a lot of conspiracy theories
Oh wait
It's basically pseudoscience. Yeah, that's what I heard
I don't know if it's true because I'm sure there's a bunch of people that are like
Oh chiropractors saved my life because before I was in intense
Before I was in intense pain
And now I'm you know healed
I
She does that almost every stream. Well, let me fucking join her. Um, what should I conspiracy theory about?
I can't really think of any recent ones that I watched
Uh
Okay, I have been watching a lot of um
A lot of those like cave diving exploration um gone wrong videos where they tell the story of some like idiot that went cave diving
I'm sorry. I shouldn't call them idiots. They're real people with families and stuff, but
Of like people that went cave diving
And they do something dumb like they're like, oh, no
You know
There was once a church called trying to recruit new members outside of the uni iton
They were like, are you ready for eternal life? Oh, fuck that reminds me. Oh, I'm sorry. I'm really bad at finishing my um
I'm really bad at finishing my train of thought. I'll come back to the cave diving stuff
The baron scene bears stuff. Yeah, the mandala effects. I believe in those for sure. I believe in that stuff
Like secretly there's like not secretly but like there's like alternate universes
Where um, you know, sometimes we we we switch between like
alternate dimensions, you know
There's a conspiracy theory that in me isn't my real sister lies lies. Don't believe them. They're trying to trick you
Don't believe what they say. Okay
It's true. I am your real sister. Okay
Don't don't don't trust them
Okay, only only trust me only trust what I say, okay
I speak the truth
Amy, have you heard of bad memory? No, are you saying I have it?
Um, yeah, I gotta wipe me. Oh, I gotta wipe my face. I'm getting sweaty
What was I talking about?
I forgot what I was talking about
Cave diving. No, I wanted to use the fan here, right? Where is the fan?
I wanted to talk about one more thing
I
Sweating all over the toys
I'm I'm I'm I'm facing the fan down here now
Here, let me let me unzip for you
And and fan inside of my sweater. Who's getting hot?
You're wearing a sweater. I know but I want to wear the sweater cuz like
You know look does it match? No, but it's close enough
It's close enough. It's it's it's you know, but it's it's on theme
Ah
Close enough good cosplay I can never truly cosplay myself could I
Okay, sure. I'll talk about the cave diving. There was actually one more thing I wanted to talk about but I forgot
I
Don't you have water I do right here. I'm drinking it
Literal fan service, huh?
Okay, okay, okay, so I've been watching like
Cave diving videos, um, we're like
Basically, I don't know. I can't think of a specific one
Just one like like some people have this really weird hobby of like
Okay, some people have this weird hobby of like putting their bodies into really tiny spaces
And seeing how far they can go basically, you know, like like the nutty putty cave guy who like
Like they just they just have this weird hobby of like
Exploration, I guess I guess it's the thrill, you know of like, ooh
I'm you know really crushed on all sides and I'm gonna try to squeeze through this tiny hole
And I have to push out all of my breath
I have to push out my entire breath to be able to squeeze through this whole
How invigorating and exciting, you know, I think some people have like that kind of thrill
That sounds like a fetish. I don't think it's a fetish
I think they just have that sort of you know, they they like to be um
They like the rush the rush, you know
But yeah, like the nutty putty guy that's the only one I actually remember
Latex kink. They should just get in a latex suit
More people they're all secretly mole furries and they're role-playing being a mole
Yeah, like people that like that parkour on the edge of like buildings, um
Hmm
It's like those kind of people that seek some strange rush
But the nutty putty cave situation is basically the story of this guy who um
He was cave diving with his friends, I think
I'm pretty sure he was cave diving with his friends. Maybe not, but I'm pretty sure he was cave diving with his friends and um
There is one part of the cave where um
You know
You have to squeeze through a really tiny hole to get to the next part of the cave, right?
And after that hole it like gets bigger again
But like these kinds of caves are literally like you crawling on your on your on your stomach like like dragging yourself
Through on your stomach, you know
So that's what the site this guy was doing and he came across, you know
That really tight part of the cave and he was like, okay. I just gotta squeeze through this hole
And it'll get wider again after I squeeze through it, right?
because people like have that cave mapped out like um
Other crazy people have gone into that cave and mapped it out
So you know where to go and you know which direction to go
To be at least a little bit safe. I don't think their their goal is to be safe doing this kind of stuff, but you know
At least a little bit safe to know at least where you are and you don't get lost in the cave forever
So he squeezes himself through the hole, right?
But the problem is is that it was actually
It was actually the wrong hole, you know
um
I don't did I do this right? Oh, there you go
No, I did this wrong. It was actually the wrong hole. He had gone
The wrong direction and he was squeezing through a different hole and this hole was actually like
really um
Really small and it would keep getting smaller and it also was um
It was also aimed um downward
It was aimed downward. So he goes through the hole and he falls in and he hangs upside down
Um, and he can't get out, right? So he's just hanging upside down
And his friends I think call for help, you know, and so they um
It takes them a while to to you know
Get to him in the first place while he's hanging upside down
Sorry if you hear bumping against the mic. It's either my headphone wire
Or my glasses
It's one of those too, sorry, um, but um
Yeah, he hangs upside down for a really long time until the rescuers come
And the rescuers are like shit, dude
Like it's gonna be really hard to break you out of here without, um
Without breaking your legs
You know
They're like we might have to break your legs to get you out of here
But then they realized I don't remember what they realized they realized like
Breaking his legs was gonna be really dangerous because he you know
I think they said it like my cause of blood clot or something
You know
I try to squeeze through the round hole before too it can get pretty messy
That's something I never quite understood. How do guys go in the wrong hole?
Like I feel like you gotta you gotta really not be paying attention
And you gotta be going really fast
To end up in the wrong hole, you know
And then that hole has to accept you in the first place
Which I feel like you'd probably know by then like oh shit. I'm going through the wrong hole, you know
No wrong no hole is wrong if you're brave enough
Slippery I'm sure it can get slippery down there. Yeah
It just hurts when it doesn't accept it. Yeah, that's what I'm saying
Like I feel like you're just
You're not actually going to be able to like go all the way in like you're just oops. Sorry poked you. Okay moving on
Anyway, um
I hope you guys don't hate me for showing my boobs. I thought it would be fun. Some people are really against flesh posting
Um, which means like showing your flesh as a vtuber
um
I think it's a little bit fun
But some people are really against it and don't like it so
I don't know
There's a lot of people and it's hard to please them all right. There's it's really hard to please everyone
I've dropped it again
Oh, I see it
Do what you want. Yeah, I will try to I love it more please
Shh shut your your mouth your dirty mouth
Um
What was I saying? Okay, now he put a cave situation right so eventually they were like, okay, we can't break his legs
I think they said something like it would cause a blood clot or something since he was hanging upside down
So they were like we can't break his legs
How about we try doing like a pulley situation since he's he's hanging upside down and like this really tight like
crevice rate so they can't just like you know
grab his legs and like
Pulled him out normally while he's like pushing like I don't know. He's probably like really dizzy at this point and barely knows
what's going on um, so
They try to do some sort of pulley situation
Where they attach the pulley to him and then they like pull from the outside right
With like maybe some sort of machine
um
But then the pulley breaks
And um
This keeps breaking too
The pulley ends up breaking and they I think in the end they just couldn't get him out
And he was stuck upside down for like 30 something hours, dude
It was crazy
But I think they got his family down there or something for him to say goodbye to
Before he died or something or at least talk to him. I can't remember
I haven't rewatched this the the story in a long time
Won't be won't be flesh stream anytime anywhere
No
No, they're they're won't no what what do you mean?
Oh
Sorry, I'm I'm growing
Oh, fuck I keep growing there's never enough in me flesh posting
You have fun you're having fun is the most important part. Yeah, that's right having fun
I
Mean I'm literally rock solid right now. Why are you acting so gay?
I'm a faucet tip 10 dollars. I don't care what other people think. I'm still rock solid right now
Please keep doing it if you're comfortable
Okay, I understand thank you for the dollars
How's anyone here sorry like that and thank you man? I want to go crawling into a tiny ass space
See that's what I'm saying because people do still do that stuff
And not only do they continue to do that stuff
Some people do it underwater
Like I legit heard us. I I like to watch them
Am I doing this wrong?
I like to watch like I get random videos on my tiktok of like people telling these stories
And I just watch them there and sometimes I'll subscribe to them. Yeah
I've only really subscribed to Stephanie Sue, but sometimes I'll go on the youtube channel to find the full stories
Because they usually only post post clips on tiktok
um
But like some people do that shit underwater like they crawl through tiny caves under the water
under the sea
under the sea, you know
And that's even scarier because not only will you get stuck you'll get stuck underwater
I finished the pot
Because I just heard this one story of two guys
And they went together underwater they were going through an underwater cave
um
and it was tight and stuff just like my poo and um they
like
Decided at one point to turn around I think and to go back. I don't remember why they decided to go back
But they decided to go back
And when they decided to go back
Oh, shit. We're already at two hours into the stream finish your freaking
Lego bitch
That reminds me of something but I don't remember why
I've seen this video and you can see the corpses more nightmare fuel. I've seen some corpses. They're very scary. They're all swollen and stuff
Uh
A fella who was cave diving in 1890
Whoa
I'm surprised most of you haven't heard of this. I'm sure some of you have
But um, yeah, there was these two guys that were uh cave diving underwater
I already did that step
And they said decide to turn back right
But then they realized as they were turning back that there was like a bunch of uh
Like sand and like um debris
On their on their road like on their tunnel on the way back and they're like, okay
Wait, this wasn't here when we got here. Um, what's going on, right?
So
They're thinking like oh, maybe we went the wrong way, you know, like
Maybe we took a wrong turn somewhere in this in this dark
Ask cave underwater and we read them went the wrong way
So they turn around and they're looking for the right way
But then they realized like no, dude, this is the right fucking way
But the problem was the reason there was debris was because um
The
Reason there was debris was because a bunch of like rocks like literally fell
From like the top of the cave
So it was like walking their way out, right? Yeah, it collapsed
Other people stopped giving funds to the family and then the poor lad basically was forgotten and died in the cave
He was stuck. Oh my god
Wait, what story are you talking about?
Oh
Oh 1890 oh
People helped at first so people got sus
If it was sure or not
Oh
He forgot and died in the cave. He was stuck in. Oh my god
Hands heart you want hands heart?
How do I do a hand heart? There we go. Hand heart
There's also like the the kpop version
Actually, I should do it with this now uh this
This is supposed to be a heart too, but this one looks more like a heart
Bro, why is my heart so weirdly shaped? There we go. Ta-da. Okay
Um
So yeah, they realized that the cave had uh
Collapsed a little bit um
In the tunnel that they were supposed to use to leave, right?
So
One guy so they were they had like 10 minutes of air left, right?
Descent is a good movie. I really like that one. I have hard time
I have a hard time finding um a good place to pirate it though
I can't find a good pirating website for descent that um has good quality
If anyone knows any pirating websites for descent that has good quality all the all the fucking versions of descent are like in
Fucking 360 pp
You're hard hardy whole
Um anyways, um
And the audio is always always fucking shit dvd. Uh
Bro, no, I don't even have a dvd player. I've been wanting to buy one eventually though
I have heard of the story of the pipeline pipeline workers. I'll tell that one next I think but I don't know that story so super well, but um
So one guy says to the other one like okay, they have like 10 minutes left, right?
And I think they were writing on like whiteboards or something underwater because obviously you can't talk to people underwater and um
One guy says to the other guy, okay, you stay here. I'm gonna go see if there's another exit, right?
So that's what he does. He leaves the other guy and he goes to look around for another exit
Unfortunately, he comes back because there's no other exit. That's the only exit, right?
Send it your way on twitter
Yeah, you can send it on twitter or a marshmallow link
But just make sure if you use a marshmallow link you you put a space in between
um in between the the dot because marshmallow doesn't
Sometimes it allows links. Sometimes it doesn't I don't know
But thank you to anyone who helped me pirate
Okay
um and when he gets back because you know, he couldn't find um
He couldn't find another way out. He realizes that his friend is fucking gone
So he's like, okay, shit. I guess he he he was able to get through, right?
um, so he's like, okay, I guess I'll go through too
but the problem is
He can't get through to the outside
without taking off his um his oxygen tank
But he's running out of oxygen anyways
I'm going to light this goddamn desk on fire if this freaking drawer opens one more time. Oh my god
Okay
So he takes off his um
Oxygen tank and he squeezes through to the other side now. They had apparently left oxygen tanks
Um
Outside of their cave. I guess maybe for a situation like this. I don't know
But they left oxygen tanks outside of the cave. I think that he the I think it was like, I don't know maybe like
A hundred meters away or something like that like that's
That's that's oh, that's really far. Maybe it wasn't a hundred meters, but they have left oxygen tanks
outside of their cave
um
So he he swam around with no oxygen until he found the extra tanks, right?
And he put put it on but then he realized oh shit
You know my friend isn't here
Um
Um, is that it?
Okay, and he realizes like oh shit my friend isn't here. Um, what do I do?
And that's because his friend was fucking dead. His friend had tried the same thing as him
to escape through without oxygen
But his friend couldn't find the tanks in time
So he died
Isn't that crazy?
Um, this isn't right
Hi Amy. Hi
I
Get really angry with this desk the drawer always opens on its own it's because I um
I'm
I placed like
Another drawer underneath like a like a
I placed an extra like fucking Walmart drawer under my desk and it's putting pressure
On the actual desk drawer, and I think that's making it open constantly. Uh
Ah
I should do an apartment tour I talked about that
I kind of want to do an apartment tour
My apartment doesn't have the best interior decor. It's very cluttered and um, I think it's a little bit cozy too though
But I'm gonna have to like clean a little bit and make sure I don't have my fucking laundry out
Because I have to dry my laundry inside of the house because I don't have a dryer
And I don't want you to see all my freaking laundry
All my dirty stinky laundry
You keep your toys in that drawer. No, I keep my art supplies in that drawer. My toys are in my closet
Dryer fund I don't have space for a dryer. I don't have anywhere to plug a dryer either
I
Had too many toys. Why do you all assume it's my toys?
You always assume it's my toys
Damn since you live like this. Yeah, people are gonna say that damn since you live like this
No
Wait a minute. Oh, I put another flower on top
You don't understand pill pin pills if you think we don't want to see your stinky laundry
I guess I don't
Okay, one more story one more story. Let me take a sip of water
Add that to the flat funds. Oh, I already have an apartment place in mind. I just have to apply to it
Which um, I haven't done yet
I really need to do that. It's just that they ask for so much
They ask for like, you know pay stubs. I um, they ask for like references from like two people, you know
They ask for a reference from your current landlord, which fucking
My current landlord either has dementia or he's autistic or he has like fucking a missing chromosome or both
He's very strange. I don't know if I'll be able to get um
I don't know if I'll be able to get any sort of note for him from him. He's really
He's um gay. Why are you guys so gay?
Link 3 22 tip 10 dollars close being left out is a plus for pin pals
Imagine my landlord is like visiting one of my neighbors
No, you don't have to prison fried pay stubs to prove your flat you have to provide pay stubs to move into a new flat
Can you prove of 10 twice the income in America? I don't know what they ask for they just ask for
Pay stubs. They don't say like you have to make a specific amount
um
I'll try to do the math to see if I would make twice the amount of the rent
But I literally don't know how to do the math
In my head
On
Oh
Oh man, I don't know how to do that. I think I would
Requires reference from your landlord. Yeah
And references from people you know in real life and they also ask a print for two months of rent
And they also asked for uh
I don't know they asked for a shit ton and it wasn't even a nice place like okay. It was a nice place, but it was like
A standard place. It was like. Yeah, this is this is like a
Standard good nice place, you know, it's not like fancy or anything
It's just like very standard place that that is good and normal and average
Yeah
Um, so it was really frustrating and then they were like
Oh
Here at stupid corp. We don't allow pets
And I was just really fancy when I went to see that lady
I was just super fancy because I was like, I don't want them to think I'm poor
So I was I I was reading through their their requirements and I look up at her and I'm like
Oh
You don't allow rats or not rats. I was like, oh, you don't allow pets to you
Well, I guess I'll take my business elsewhere then
I was like, oh, you don't allow pets, huh?
I guess uh, I guess I won't be able to apply here and then she was like, oh, no, no, no, no
No, no, no
It's okay. It's okay. It's okay
They just say that on on on the requirements so that they can kick you out if you don't pay rent and use that as an excuse
And I was like, okay damn, okay
Um anyways
That's evil of them, I know
I know
Also, I'm pretty sure
I don't know. I thought oh this doesn't fit. Oh, yeah, but I don't know
I know in some places it's like illegal for landlords to decide. Um
I know in some places it's illegal for landlords to decide whether or not you're allowed to have a pet
Which is based and true and real and they should do that in more places
Thank you for becoming a pin pal Gerald
Is that Gerald from the video game?
What's it called?
Is that Gerald from?
Um
Sassans Creed
The Witcher!
Is that Gerald from The Witcher?
Yeah, The Witcher
I know video games
um
Most apartments in the US charge you monthly for pets too. Yeah, they don't do that here, but they do um
A lot of them do say no pets allowed in the first place
I don't know video games
Sorry, I don't know video games
Gerald for the famous game Mass Effect
Okay, yeah, I wanted to tell you one more story or I guess two more stories
Oh, I realized I just forgot what the second one I wanted to tell you
Oh, yeah, it was about these people on a boat
I got I get a lot of these stories from uh, Mr. Ballin on youtube
He tells like crazy stories
His titles are like really fucking clickbaity, but then his stories are actually like
interesting, so
um this other one is um
Fucking um
Like I think it was like this one dude um had a younger brother out
Oh, sorry I'm getting hot
Should I should I take my sweater off?
I'm not gonna take it off all the way, but I'll unzip it
I put the fan down there
I know some people let their pets ruin housing i.e walls and carpet
I I can't say I can't say anything about that because I've also done that
Okay
Um
Right this one was um, it was about like some guy and he had a younger brother and his younger brother was like I guess into
Boats and stuff and he he's he had some experience with that
But I guess his younger brother was more experienced and they didn't have enough people on their crew
To go on this to by the way, most of these stories I listen to like while I'm doing something else
So I probably am getting some details wrong, but they didn't have enough people to go on their on their on their um
Other expedition
Huh
What
Oh
Wait, why won't it connect
Huh
Is it just supposed to sit on it
Oh, maybe I did place the side pieces too low
Uh
Um
Hmm
Anyways, so his brother was like hey, oh, I think I did thank you. You're right his brother was like hey, um, can you
You know, can you come with us on this trip and he was like sure
Yeah, sure. I'll come with you. You guys are missing some crew members. I'll just come with you
and um
As they were as they were uh
Going I think what happened was like there was some boat malfunction. So they like go down into the you know the boat to try to fix it
and um
And as he was doing that they were realizing like holy shit the boat is flooding, you know
They're like, oh my god, the boat is flooding
So they get on their um, and it was like really flooding badly. So they get on their um
On the on the safety raft
Lego has always been a two-person job
One person fiddles with the figuring out how to get the thing together while the other reads instructions or sorts pieces
Oh, well, this is so easy a baby could do this. I don't need anyone else
I don't need anyone to help me
other than maybe you
um
So they get on the life the the safety raft like the you know the emergency raft
And um
Once they're like kind of far away from the boat they realize like holy shit
um
I forgot what I was gonna say holy shit the raft has a hole in it and the raft was like leaking too, right?
someone fucking had to have
Trolled them a little bit, but um
So they realize even the raft had a leak in it, right the safety raft
And so now they're like frick shit. What do we do? What do we do? What do we do? You know even the safety raft is gonna
Is gonna um
Maybe i'm too sick for some reason your voice sounds a bit like project melody. Oh my god does it that's a that's a fucking
That's a compliment for me
I
Can I use the freaking microphone allow project melody I didn't want to I didn't want to tape it all out
Like oh, I have you too
Absolutely
Okay, a starian. I need to give you some clothes. I'm gonna sell my project melody. There you go buddy much better
Oh my god. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. That was what she was wearing. Okay. Okay. Okay. Um, let me
You don't watch and you don't watch enough vtubers if you think I sound like project melody
She does sound cute though
Maybe
I am really sick. Yeah, you are sick get your ears checked. Also, Amy your mic on messed up
What
Oh, fuck no, no one was gonna tell me that I have my mic on I don't have my mic on mono
Oh, dude. I'm so sorry to anyone listening with headphones
There
You're only in our right ear
No, it's gonna fucking tell me that
Anyone who is listening with headphones was probably hearing the only in one ear
Oh, it just happened wait, seriously
I just thought Amy was to my right. No
It's been like that the whole street
No, it's gonna fucking tell me
It only just started wait, what? It only happened when you pull up on youtube. What?
What the fuck that's weird
It sounded okay before
It has not been like that the whole stream, huh?
I don't know
I did have my mic on uh stereo or whatever the fuck it's called for the the
The 3DO ASMR stream though. I have to switch it for every fucking ASMR stream
And then I always forget to to switch something back afterwards
Okay, anyways
I'm using headphones. It's been fine this whole time for you until you until the youtube clip. That's so weird. That's so strange
So, um
Your audio also sounds different compared to pre youtube switching
Bro, has my audio been like fucked this whole stream?
Was my was was my mic bad or something?
That's wrong thing
No, it was peaking kind of bad
You're right, that's fine
Hold on i'm going back to i'm going back to the stream. I'm super super um
Like i'm super super picky you're getting one guide
That happens a lot. I'm super super picky about you tried. Uh
Huh
I don't know
I sound like my usual annoying ass self. Audio's fine. Okay
She's so artistic. I'm just really picky about my audio sounding normal at least and okay and good
It seems very easy to one guy and me it is it is very easy
We love spreading this information
Okay, um
You sound amazing always don't say that. Oh, okay. Thank you
okay, so um
They were like, okay, what do we do? What do we do? So they decide okay one guy this this one guy
He's the main character. He's like, okay. I'm the biggest dude, right? So he's he's the
The biggest one. He's the one weighing down the the safety raft. So he's like i'm going to
Jump off of the safety raft and i'm going to swim back to the sinking boat
That's what he he decides and everyone's like no, that's a that's death wish
You're gonna die well because the sinking boat was pretty far at this point
They're like you're gonna fucking die if you do that like don't do that
Don't do that and he's like it's fine because in the back of his head
He's like oh, there's a rat at my feet in the back of his head. He's like, you know what
If I don't do this then no one has a chance, you know
Is that really how it's supposed to look that looks stupid
He's like if I don't do this then no one has a chance of living, right?
Oh, I guess that is how it's supposed to look. So he gets off
Stopped peeking now too, huh?
I don't know
No, there are not rats on the boat. I'm saying there's a rat at my feet right now
Not on the boat
Um
Not on the boat. Um
Um, it's fun to one guy in me
You're the only one I want to one guy me
um
So he he gets off the the like safety raft and he he does it. He's he's thinking it's a death. Um, you know
It's it's it's kind of you know a a lost cause, but at least his friends will be able to
Oh, it's pixie. Hi pixie. Oh, sorry. Fuck. It's luna. No, it's pixie. It's pixie. I get their names confused. Um
So he he just thinks like at least my friends will be able to be safe for a little longer
And I still might have a chance of swimming back to the to the sinking ship maybe right
So he swims for like hours straight like fucking. I don't even know like a day or something
And um
And he finally gets there
Oh, I'm done
He finally gets there and you know, he he's like, okay great. We're good
And then he like stays there for a really long time
And eventually he sees a big ship
Go up to like where his friends were and he's like, holy shit
My friends were saved right and sees since he's not too far away from from them because he saw the ship saving them
He's thinking like, okay, maybe um
Maybe i'll be saved too
So, um
He falls asleep thinking like oh when I wake up. I'll be in the hospital with my friends, right?
And um
And um, oh shit Estefan is here. Hi Estefan
Hi
Have you come to torment me?
Now that I'm done you've come to steal a piece
huh
And then pixie's like
Playing in the in the packaging in the plastic packaging. I'm trying to get Estefan to come here
But I don't think she wants to she's like right over here in this corner
Nice your game is still fucked by the way
Are you one guy? Are you one guying me right now?
Are you one guying me right now?
I'm being serious wait
I'm here to check my game
I can't tell she keeps letting him one guy her you still kind of peek yet. What the fuck?
The audio quality is kind of fucked
It is kind of fucked wait what happened wait
What's wrong with my audio what happened?
Oh, she's walking on my get off of my keyboard she's walking on my keyboard
Whatever the stream is almost done. I'll see if I can fix it another time. I don't know
I don't know what it could be if there's actually anything wrong and everybody accuses me of one guy
Are you guys trolling me right now? Are you guys trolling me?
I think you're not trolling me. I think it is kind of fucked
It's clipping a bit
Oh
Whatever
It's fine. We're done now. Here it is
It's fine. We're done the stream. I'll fix it another time. I'll fix it another time
We're done
I'll fix it for next stream. I'm sorry
Ever since you opened youtube it's random crunchy audio. It's because my rat is playing with the plastic wrapping of the um
Of the legos
And also with my chocolate
She's in the background like playing with the plastic wrap
That might be why you hear crunching in the background. I don't know
Whatever
Um
Crunchy you not background noise. Oh, I'm crunchy. Oh, I'm crunchy
Oh man, what if I unplug and plug it back in?
Is that better
Did that do anything? I don't know. It's okay. We're we're in the extreme. So there's no point in um
Missing around for now. It is better. What the fuck?
What the fuck?
Are you shitting me
Back to pre-youtube. So it's the youtube me opening youtube that fucked it up. That's so strange
Worse now. Okay, whatever
I don't even know anymore
See who's streaming. Um
She's really playing with the chocolate wrapper. It's really cute. I'm not sure who to raid. Um
Um
Is anyone in you may
Is anyone in you may plus streaming right now, um
Oh my god
Do
No, shit rain
No, oh she is she is sorry. I didn't see it. Okay. We'll raid we'll raid rain
We will raid rain
Also, thank you so much my freaking video. Um, my teaching your shy girlfriend how to kiss videos is uh
Is on is is is on a one out of ten for for views by hour
I don't I don't think that makes sense
It's got more views. Um
In the first five hours than my other videos. So that's nice. Thank you
I'm happy you like it
Let me
Figure out how to raid rain now
Oh
Customization
The hug at the start of the video is amazing. I'm glad you like it
Okay, um
I finished that I'm gonna move my mic so it's normal again
Here we go. Oh bro right as I change away from the hand cam
Someone came here to visit
Come here
Look who came to visit. Oh, she's so cute. She's really shy and scared
Let's not let's not steal any Lego pieces. Okay
Oh, she's so precious
What's up you want to get on top she's on top of me now
Oh
She's on my shoulder, okay
Um, I'll go back to the just chatting screen
Okay
I'm kissing her. She's just crawling around me. Um never wanted to be a rat so badly
She can go in my shirt if she wants
But you can't ha ha
You wish you were me you want to play with her
Um
Thank you for coming to our lego building stream. I don't know if I'll do more
I might
Um
What else
I'll see you tomorrow for our taste testing stream
I got a bunch of of different flavors of
Silly juice
And um
We're gonna have a lot of fun there
I'm probably gonna go back to playing that animal crossing princess
pretty princess animal crossing knockoff
um
Because it's actually kind of fun. I'm not gonna lie. She's trying to get on my tits. Should I do another tip reveal?
Oh
Oh my god, that's a lot
Bro, someone's gonna fucking to shame me on how far apart they are too. I can hear it coming
Um, I'll see you tomorrow
Uh
Yeah, I don't I'm like out of things to say but yeah
I'll see you tomorrow. I ran out of water too. Damn. Okay. Bye. Bye. Love you
Don't tell anyone. Okay. Don't tell anyone. I showed anything
Okay, bye-bye
Oh